What's Happening Now
Allah you know Subhan
Allah we have
to raise
awareness what's happening to our
brothers and sisters
intine because what's happening without
any Shadow of Doubt they want to destroy
the Z they want to destroy going to okay
so but what is very
shocking that when you see the Western
world where they were ja us crazy
because of Putin invaded
Ukraine okay when when Russia killed one
Ukrainian as if they Putin killed the
whole world but when this Zionist
terrorist Netanyahu killing innocent
people in Gaza as if nothing is
happening and don't be surprised when
you see Christians doing nothing about
it because the Christians are the slaves
of the
Zionist as my family came from a
Christian
background remember you know they have
this this mindset of you cannot speak
against against soal Israel because they
are The Chosen One by God so don't
expect the Christians this uh extremist
to help you you understand so you can
see that Christian woman there look at
the Indian Christian raising the flag
you know there's no country called
Israel I don't accept it and let me tell
you even if Sai and Israel they do PE
treat I don't accept country Israel I
don't care you see so I tell you
something about me you understand there
is not and we're not going to Free palan
by protesting men women free mixing and
shouting woman musl Muslim women should
not be screaming in the
streets that's not the E of Muslim woman
like go and against Allah's teaching so
how this Muslim woman shout in Palestine
Allah is going to ha us through her when
she's opposing Allah you know so we
don't we don't support Palestine by
doing Haram you understand we're not
going to support Palestine by opposing
the Quran I'm supporting Palestine by
raising awareness about this evil
Zionist terrorist Netanyahu what he's
doing to our
brother and what is amazing and shock I
what is shocking you know this was
name how this uh uh P
Morgan he's too hard for him to condemn
what his Z are doing as if the world
started on the S of October like there's
not exist before that everything started
on the 7th of October so he doesn't want
to tell us what happened in
1948 he doesn't want to tell us what
happened in 1967 no only 2003 October
that's it I don't know I believe I was
born before that you know how did the
universe kept existence but show you
that's why when there's a fan Allah
expose lies for the fan you know
hypocrisy double standard Ukraine Putin
is evil why because he cut off
electricity and water and food for the
ukrainians nanahu same thing but is a
good
person try to rationalize this for me
try to make it
logical it's clear because they are
white and the people are getting killed
they are
brown you know if they were white
European you see how the Western will
raise up and they talk about human
rights and they they care about human
life clearly this Zionist terrorist
Netanyahu he's breaking human rights u
rules and regulations but Subhan Allah
Allah exposed them anyway Allah exposed
them you know this Main media I don't
believe nothing from them cuz they were
the same people they T us that Saddam
had nuclear weapon weapons are massiveu
yeah massive same people you know so
there's a way likewise when you see
Jewish people walking the street don't
oppress them that's how you support
Palestine because you oh I'm you look
like some brothers they're protesting
when they see Starbucks they start
throwing glasses on why you why you
breaking people cars there's many Jewish
people are zist who are protesting in
America in Britain no so Islam teach us
if someone of if a Jewish man if a
Jewish or a Christian oppress me I'm not
allowed to go oppress any Christian or
Jewish that's not Islamic teaching or
even his own sister allowed to oppress
her you know that's Islamic teaching
that's Prophet Muhammad's
teaching you know so this human rights
that they talking about Islam we have
the best human rights in a war you know
allow to kill women and children you
know but again on the other hand which
many people are SC speak about what's
Hamas are doing why Hamas are hiding the
leader of Hamas is not Hamas is not a
leader of Palestine I'm I'm not with
Hamas I'm with my I am with my
Palestinian brothers and sisters and I
support them to defend themselves and to
free their
country with everything but I'm with ham
Hamas are hiding why who's getting
killed now
ftin they came out after when they bomb
the hospital when they come out going to
say you know what we're going to take
revenge we're going to destroy these
enemies you know what they said all the
Muslims in the Arab world go out and go
out and protest wait wait wait wait how
us protesting in our countries is going
to save the Palestinians in
Gaza so you it doesn't help so you
started something you cannot maintain
do you know what I say to you my dear
brother and sister you have Allah with
you Allah is with you there's some out
there they are United against you to
destroy
[Music]
you Subhan Allah they have no weapons
nothing Subhan Allah and the even
recently they ex they send a rocket to
where is on church or something they d
church but she's a Christian doesn't
care about the church you see the
Christians are hypocrites they're not
speaking about the church I course
there's many Christian
Palestinian festini Christians there is
and they get oppressed Subhan Allah man
say Allah help you my brothers and
sister intine that's the only thing I
can say and the other thing I can say I
can use my time to protect you and
defend you and that's why I do here
alhamdulillah we some zist come to try
to justify they have a right to control
Philistine I Expos them historically
religiously intellectually everything
alhamdulillah like I did with the family
they came here philistin belong to
Palestinians the Jewish people are happy
they they can live there but it belong
to them you know Subhan Allah but
alhamdulillah Allah with
us
Allah mentioned don't not be don't think
Allah is unaware what the oppressed are
doing Allah has giving them a Time Allah
is delain them to a day when they'll be
humiliated don't worry you know so just
be strong alhamdulillah what you see
from our brothers some our brother Stine
inaz you take a listen from it Mah did
you see that brother he was in in the
hospital and he said other brother don't
cry he giving them
what everything's easy for us we
complain subh Allah everything's easy
for us but we complain we always
complain we don't even say alhamdulillah
this brother M happy smiling even though
he just lost his son or his
brother you know Subhan
Allah but we so we don't look look ald
the salafi way is the Quran Sunnah
protesting is going to help us going to
help you shouting you know we have our
brother
you start helping yourself first if you
do not pray you are in a Calamity as I
said many times you are occupied by Shan
you have been invaded by Shan long time
ago yes and please also some people go
to ex about Philistine don't make
Philistine as a criteria if you with
Philistine you're evil man if you
against it you're a good man why I'm
saying that as and brothers sharing
videos of some people that hate Islam
but they are
ftin I mean Islam is the CR I Isam is a
criter over my head and my family and my
emotion and anyone else Quran andah
someone insult Prophet Muhammad wasallam
because he defend for I'm going to
spread his video and support him no Pro
is a criteria you know so that's why in
a time of Allah Expos many people some
people but Allah and Quran Sunnah over
everything you know you see some
brothers just yesterday I saw a group of
people coming free free palistine
Allah guide them
man we have to go back to learn our de
and Allah promised that he will give us
the
victory
M you remember there was a drought
during his lifetime and he was making
Dua and his Dua Allah never accepted his
Dua why why cuz one person was
committing a sin not five one person one
person was committing sin at the time of
M so imagine our time how many of us
committing
sins that's why Allah
mentioned sometimes your sin can affect
other
Muslims you see Subhan Allah so that's
what we have to do make Dua if you have
a platform utilize your platform to
raise awareness expose the terrorists
who are killing innocent people in Gaza
okay and uh likewise if you know Char
organization that is legit and is going
to take the money to those who deserves
it then send help them with
money even the the Europeans that are
coming out some of them because that's
what Islam teach us we should not
generalize every English person or
Spanish person because there is people
amongst the British or the English and
the the Spanish who are speaking out and
guess this genocide is happening in Gaza
Subhan
Allah